Please welcome Aya Cash.
(audience cheering)
People were really obsessed
with "The Girl from Plainville" story.
It's very dark, it's everywhere in the news right now.
Tell me what drew you to it.
You know, I followed the case in real time
when it was happening.
And I think that like most people,
I was completely shocked and titillated by the story
in a way that I think I look back on now,
and feel differently.
I think that the documentary that came out on "HBO"
really shifted my thought about this.
And we're sort of looking back at women,
and how we've treated young women in the media
in a different way, whether it's Britney Spears,
or Paris Hilton or Monica Lewinsky.
And this is a young girl who did something pretty horrific,
but our telation with that is also something to be examined.
And I think this is a re-telling that gives these two
children a real re-telling.
Oh that's so interesting.
This was really interesting.
I am a crossword fanatic.
I am obsessed, and people loved you
from "You are the Worst."
And there's a crossword story there, tell me about it.
Basically, all my dreams came true and I was
in the "New York Times" Crossword.
That's so huge.
What did Will Shortz give for you as a clue?
'Cause he really does like to mind twist people.
Yeah, this was not so complicated.
I think I'm obscure enough that they could
just say, "Cash actress of You are the Worst."
I like that, it's straightforward,
and I can work with that.
I don't like being sent down a rabbit hole,
upon another rabbit hole, upon another rabbit hole.
Although, you know what rabbit hole I could get into,
like every time?
I've seen it probably 10 times, "The Wolf of Wall Street,"
which you are in.
One of my favorite movies of all time.
What was it like to work with
the one and only Leonardo DiCaprio?
This is the big reveal.
He's a horrible human being.
No, he knows everyone's name.
He's kind, he works hard, he knows his lines,
he's just absolutely lovely, he spent...
He also works very hard.
He had this scene where he was eating sushi, he and Jonah.
They're eating sushi and they improv for like two hours,
and Leo, you know, is actually eating sushi
during all of that, and had to take little breaks
to actually relieve himself into a bucket
between the takes, and that's, that's commitment.
You know that you really love someone,
kind of like your child, you're like, "I wouldn't mind
watching Leo throw up."
Well, it was all rainbows and unicorns coming out of him.
I bet it was, I knew it, I knew it.
(upbeat music)